just your friendly scummy traffic cone
here to provide you with some
unnecessary content no hi my name is
Chris hobbies do not know know you know
your life it's different now there's
been a huge trend on YouTube of people
turning themselves into Bratz dolls how
it started I don't know will it ever end
I don't know and I want to participate
some way I do not own a Bratz doll
growing up so I don't have a personal
connection to them however I was a brat
growing up so I have a personal
projection on them I don't want to go
back to those days so instead here we
are well you guys know I like a good
transformation I've done drag makeup
tutorial transformations I've turned
myself into my dog I've turned myself
into a puppet for your entertainment
only and so of course I love a good
transformation I went on Twitter and
asked you guys what should I transform
myself into if not a Bratz doll and a
lot of you said gritty which makes sense
because he's my newfound obsession I'm
getting too obsessed with it
this will provide some closure this will
get me to the like the level in which I
need to stop that's what we're doing
today we're gonna transform ourselves
into gritty I don't know if you've like
ever looked into gritty cuz I have fear
that we're gonna I'll take cue from
gritty that you just got to be on a
Bosch of the yourself
[Music]
and also maybe a little bit less cocaine
in our blown-out all the time Britney's
a mascot for the Philadelphia Flyers and
he just just blown us all away by his
insanity unadulterated but maybe
adulterated sense of mischievousness
also if you've ever looked up gritty
online it's got a full backstory its dad
was a bully so he likes to surround
people I didn't go out to the store to
buy myself any provisions for this I'm
only using what I have on hand and
luckily for me I have some face paint
from videos Pat has it like the expired
oh yeah am I gonna put it directly into
my pores oh yeah also this is the only
orange thing I own so camille makeshift
okay
also just gathered a bunch of [ __ ] and
turn the camera on
i don't have a game plan guess we start
with orange sure oh we start by taking a
goddamn shot that's how we get into the
mind of a makeup master that's how we
start to look a little bit more strong I
like gritty I purposely didn't take a
shower just so I could shoot this video
first that's the reason I haven't
showered my forehead looks big a good
thing is my orange has some like dark
colors mixed into it from I don't
remember what
so this paints old let's smash it into
our skin
Ernie's face is slightly like more
Hamburglar in shape just doing a general
face first this is what Wednesday looks
like if you look closer at gritty it's
got very beautiful eyes you know what I
just realized
Merl Orange another famous fictitious
creature that wears all orange is
Garfield and I literally just like a
recently divorced dad heated up a
Stouffer's lasagna for mice I don't
Trumper gritty neither one knows how to
run the country but one of them brings
us joy something actually very soothing
about this I feel great I feel great I
feel great
[Laughter]
Oh Internet sometimes I think I've
matured out of you're tempting me mARMS
and then this happens okay I think our
base is done you know this is gonna be
oddly the video that my parents are most
proud of this is a little wet we're
gonna let dry oh do I have any
deliveries happening today yeah I don't
have anything going on except going to a
bar wrestling event later tonight you
imagined this [ __ ] gonna bar I think
we're gonna make the whites of the eyes
and then do the eyeballs on top of our
eyeballs again from my goose tutorial
has been compromised with a darker color
so let's see how she goes oh boy oh boy
oh boy so like what it what's your face
your favorite mascot hmm okay so gritty
has like almond shaped eyes and it loves
a good black eyeliner like all Jersey
Philadelphia role model should we're
just gonna get into these eyes let's see
what happens oh please don't let any of
my neighbor's need a favor right now oh
I feel really confident in my life
choices yeah I'm getting competitive
with myself that I don't want this to be
bad oh god I just want to do gritty it's
due diligence pretty you deserve the
best I look like I'm like one of the
members of Blue Man groups like shitty
half sister it's like you you're blue
well what's that movie where everyone's
a feeling this looks like the reject
feeling I'm not too excited about this I
hope one of your goddamn parents walks
in on you watching this right now your
child is making a good decision good
choices they're good so gritty like
myself no stranger into some like black
liquid eyeliner we're gonna attempt to
mimic that scenario and it does not for
a winged liner it's just a straight
outline yeah pain my pain am i ugly
oh god I'm scared dammit we're pushing
up okay we'll do a thinner line
underneath cuz I know you can't bear it
coos your mom's busy she's in a
conference call right now he's doing her
job provide for you all right well that
didn't go as well as I wanted to but
gritty also has like what glam and gore
do she would fix this not my best work
I'll be the first to admit this is
get a little bit more garfield than
gritty right now so I need to do the
eyes I can't do this
no good it look like a circle I don't
want to do gritty dirty
it's a can't see that was horrifying
look I'm not using the best brushes
that's the only reason this might turn
out that oh my gosh that look at all out
I have so much [ __ ] in my eye right now
it's continues to look absolutely
[ __ ] horrifying I'll put the orange
around it it's not a good idea orange
for orange pupils okay that's it the
People's Choice how are you okay
my eyes are tearing I added some orange
to the other side I have some fixing up
to do I'm literally crying oh great he
doesn't cry now we're gonna work on this
big dumb mouth mouth is something I can
relate to it is always a game seemingly
to happy bordering on the point revenge
you bought resting [ __ ] Grady's got
like resting psychotic revenge face
let's see if we can mimic that in this
mouth that looks compromising Oh
gritties French turns out I don't like
what's about to happen either just an
actual psychopath this is harder than I
thought I was gonna be dammit dammit
it's not this is bad and you know what I
retract what I said earlier hope your
parents walk into your room right now
oh stop my eyes watering oh this is
embarrassing I'm just sad gritty may be
gritty PMS is we don't know no no I got
too excited about the mouth it's way too
big
we gotta cover this mouth a little bit
yeah we'll just add some some texture
here that was the wrong choice I'm
getting impatient I'm making better
choices do I must seem like we're gonna
add texture because gritty hair is
covered in face I'm not gonna cover my
hair and face what did I just say
oh no I've taken on the full impact of
gritty which is complete and utter
nonsense it's got this like reddish
color here so I'm gonna add a little bit
of red and just sort of see what happens
I let this dry so now it just looks like
brown dirt oh that doesn't look like
gritty at all so bad this really goes to
show that gritty is 1 million this is
incredibly bad I'm not gonna stop though
that looks like gritty gritties tongue
is all the way to the enemy this is the
worst thing I've done in a long time a
little tongue that sticks out here oh
I'm getting gross though dang it out
dang it cute this isn't soon good no so
when you put pink over wet black is not
the best trying to make the gritty smile
smaller so I can actually use my time
horrifying what were we thinking this is
the worst I'm just taking the lock I'm
gonna make some makeshift accoutrements
accessorize and see how gritty turns out
yet this is really bad
I hate if anyone saw this they would
take my dogs away from me
and about to get gritty I can't even
pose we did it everyone's doing those
Bratz dolls recreations but we did
gritty here we go
[Music]
[Applause]
come on here I mean come on this is a
pretty spot we'll need to get into the
Nitty Gritty of it it's pretty good
grace helbig 33 and thriving well that's
it for this video of transforming myself
into gritty that seems appropriate let
me know in the comments down below how
well you think I did and who or what I
should transform myself into next as
even though the results are usually
awful the journey is a real treat over
here to subscribe to this YouTube
channel I make videos whenever the [ __ ]
I want these days and turn on the bail
notifications so that you don't miss a
second of this I mean it's really good
and I know it I don't need your
validation I don't know oh I like it but
it's scary
alright guys